Other clarification about rife use and foot baths, we get questions weekly basis about the use of the rife and using other programs.
Okay, so make this perfectly clear.
The rife should be your first go to for everything.
Now, I do not believe the rife is a panacea for every disease known to man, but it should be your first go to.
I have an earache run the ear infection program.
I have, you know, use your use wisdom if you broke your arm, don't try to run a program of the rife to heal your heart, but it should be a go to program.
I have a rash.
I should run the inflammation program or find a program that may be fitting. There's poison ivy. I think programs on the rife.
So try to use the rife as a tool to help with any of your ills or any of your problems without becoming a crazy hypochondriac that's that your husband divorces you because you're sitting in front of the rife all the time, but it should be your first go to tool.
You can't hurt yourself. Run in any programs on the rife. So use them.
Clarification about the foot baths. Make sure if you're using the foot bath apparatus, you are switching.
Follow the instructions in your manual. Flip the switch to bath and run only on pro wave programs with your foot bath.
Do not run other programs with your foot bath. There are programs to be run with the ball. That's 99% of the programs on your rife.
And then there's a folder that says ion pro wave. Those are the programs that you can run with your foot bath.
Now many of you I have put an ion pro wave program that I want you to run in your folder. Many of you I have it, but the ones that have that in your folder, then run that program.
So just be clear about that. Look up your instructions. Every one of you is given a rife annual spiral bound kind of thing.
And just look that up if you're, if you're unclear about that, if you have to call the clinic, you can go ahead and do so.